to announce the nominees for art
direction handsome man who got the
pretty woman and a pretty woman who got
an Oscar nomination for Atlantic City
ladies and gentlemen Richard Gere and
Susan Sarandon
our directors create the world of the
past the present and the future and make
it all seem real and sometimes they're
called upon to create worlds that never
were and the best of them make that
believable - and the best of them is
whom we honor tonight
okay this year's nominees for art
direction are cyrano de bergerac art
direction by ezo rogério direct
decoration by jacques excel excellent
Dances with Wolves art direction by
Jeffrey Beecroft set decoration by Lisa
Dean Dick Tracy art direction by Richard
silver set decoration by Rick Simpson
Godfather Part three art direction by
Dean Savile eres hiding set decoration
by Gary Ferris Hamlet our decoration by
Dante Ferretti set decoration by
Francesca lo Schiavo
and the Oscar goes to Richard Silbert
for Dick Tracy and for separation Rick
Simpson
I want to thank the many groups of
artists and craftsmen who contributed to
the making of a handmade movie like Dick
Tracy but the one group I would really
like to thank is Warren Beatty not only
on this occasion but the group and I
have been here before and this is the
first opportunity I've had them to thank
them for not only this picture but the
past as well thank you all members of
the Academy